so welcome today we're talking with Ian
Gibbons who nearly 50 years ago
discovered the molecular motor protein
dining so dining is a force generating
ATPase that causes cilia and flagella to
beat it's also found in the cytoplasm of
most eukaryotic cells where it
transports all kinds of different cargo
such as small membrane vesicles the
Golgi apparatus the nucleus it
transports mRNAs and protein complexes
and in mitosis it also plays an
important role in constructing the
mitotic spindle so it's a very important
molecule in in cell biology and well
I've known in for many years we've
collaborated on several occasions but
I've never had a chance really to sit
down and talk to you about how this
whole story came about how you and went
up went about discovering dining so well
let's go back to when it all started in
1963 and maybe you can tell me about
what captivated your interest in
studying cilia and flagella in the first
place I was working as an electron
microscopy at Harvard in the biology
labs and I was collaborating on a
project involving looking at flagella in
a in the various flagellated protozoa
and one of the one of the days we hadn't
we were happened to take some pictures
by accident of that showed a set of
cross-sections of cilia and flagella and
the transition between the basal body or
centriole up into the shaft of the axon
II and there were an enormous variety of
ripple or structures there that had
never been described previously and I
felt that they must be doing something
important
I knew that cilia and flagella were
motile organisms my supervisor at
Cambridge was getting my PhD was John
Bradfield and he had actually written a
paper on cilia and flagella mechanisms
at that time but then he left the field
completely and went into finance so I
decided that when I took this all these
beautiful structures I really wanted to
know more about how how they might hell
they might work there was somewhat
structure there it was far from obvious
as to what it might do how the different
bits might interact so which of these
structures did you think might be the
force generating entity and then how did
you actually go about figuring that out
well I didn't get there all in one go it
took several time several stages and one
of the things was that that after I'd
spent a couple of years doing electron
microscopy I realized that one only got
a rather limited distance looking at
structure alone because it was almost
nothing known about the chemistry and
not a great deal about the detailed
motility and so I decided to take on the
biochemistry kind go for it myself
though I had no experience in
biochemistry but I did have my wife who
was an experienced protein biochemist
working in John had sorts laboratory at
that time and she certainly provided me
with lots of help in getting started and
knowing the important questions that our
fish should be considering so once I did
that then I decided that the Tetrahymena
cilia were an interesting model or
organism from which to isolate the cilia
since one can grow them up by the pound
and and isolate them actually I bought
myself a cream separator to harvest them
we didn't get maybe about a pound of
tetrahymena in each culture so then from
that I used the method for isolating the
cilia that had been developed by Sir
John Randall's lab in London and use
that to isolate Sicilia that's he his
people had tried to look at the proteins
but but they hadn't gotten very far
because they found that the proteins
appear to be to come almost completely
insoluble
I suspected that the problem had been
that the the isolated cilia after they
fractured from the cell
so remembering healed over the the
isolated tip and and so the cilium was
in completely enveloped by the membrane
and so the proteins couldn't get out
when I got these preparations if I said
cilia then I I I decided that the first
thing to do was get rid of the membrane
so I applied a mild detergent did you
turn in that did a wonderful job of
taking off the membranes and also showed
that the structure remained intact see
all the internals the bits of the
ciliary apparatus remained intact and
what very importantly also the cilia
retained there that's anymore and ATPase
activity very little disappeared with
the membrane so we had the up denuded
acronyms when I just put them into a
concentration solution of salt the
protein all completely dissolved that
showed that they were solid that you had
access to all the protein but it wasn't
what I wanted I wanted to get some
fractionation and that I achieved by
extracting them at lower and it strength
with EDTA to completely remove any
divalent cations when I did that I found
I got a very interesting separation of
the protein into two fractions a soluble
fraction and an a and the residual
pellet and comparing those two
structures in the electron microscope I
saw that the extraction with those
thought EDTA had removed all this
central apparatus the spokes the two
central t wheels and in addition had
removed the arms near outer arms that
ran along the length of the doublet
microtubules when I looked at the
solubility of protein and
ATPase I found that the that this had
indeed achieved a good separation
because the the solid solute at that
solid soluble fraction contained about
80% of the total initial
ATPase activity but only had about 30%
of the total protein so I'd obtained
something that a three-fold purification
is by doing this simple and straight
and so since I had most of the 80 max
anymore ATP is present in the soluble
fraction obviously the thing to do was
to look at it and the only technique one
had at the time this was before gel
electrophoresis the only technique
available was centrifugation started
with an analytical centrifuge and there
there were three peaks one slow one at
for s1 at 14s and one at 30 years when I
ran the same material on a sucrose
density gradient and I said four ATPase
activity then I found that the ATPase
activity was completely confined to the
14s and 30-years fractions the 4s had on
essentially none that was the largest
fraction in terms of a total protein so
then the question was which of those
various structures that had disappeared
and yet had the answer anymore ATP is
actually come from and to find that out
I tried recombining I took the solid
soluble fraction in the pellet fraction
and mix them together and in the
presence of magnesium and fortunately I
found that a major fraction of the
ATPase activity that had been extracted
in solution became rebound to the to the
pellet fraction looking in the electron
microscope this showed that the
structures that had reappeared when the
ATPase activity became rebound were the
two arms that stick out from each of the
doublet two bills so this was pretty
strong evidence that yes any more ATP
A's was indeed localized in these arms
in our homes on the doublet tubules so
now you had this ATPase you could show
that you can add it back and it could
reconstitute this really interesting
structure between the two outer doublets
so our next step how did you come up
with the name of this interesting ATPase
once we had the protein more purified
David the name down in dining but the
dime was unit of force I'm the only unit
of force present when I went through
school actually Barbara was the one who
suggested the name Danny
she suggested in one evening at her
so at that time how do you think it
worked well there were two theories
running there were two possible
mechanisms one would be a mechanism
involving localized contractions that
somehow the section such that localized
sections are on the length of the
microtubule might change the crystal
crystallize packing arrangement of
subunits in a way similar to that which
the bacterial flagellum does when it
changes its shape from a left-handed
helix to a right-handed heel it's under
the influence of a chemotactic
attractant that will be one possible
mechanism second possible mechanism was
that microtubules would slide relative
to one another and that this weren't
opposed by a resistance to bending were
calls the been what caused the formation
of a new Bend difficulty with that
mechanism was that to have bends of
opposite directions at different
positions along the length of the exonym
meant that the individual microtubules
and microtubules run straight along the
length of the axon but it meant that the
sliding has to be in opposite directions
in order to bet generate bends of
opposite directions at different
positions even where you're only speak
thinking of a single mine that's a
microtubule
that seemed to be to me a major obstacle
and so that I put I didn't take it any
further at that time actually you look
in the text of the paper I was actually
leaning toward that contractile
hypothesis so then what did you do next
it was time to do an experiment so what
kind of what experiment discern between
these two mechanisms laughter we tighten
the formality publishing the more
purified protein and end the name which
is 1965 then I realized that we needed
to study get more into the motility and
the Tetrahymena cilia were extremely
inconvenient for doing that because
there are only five micrometers long and
though you didn't see them you can see
there wagging fade Lee when you look
with a high-powered
like microscope lens which you can never
measure accurately the parameters of
waveforms so that was when I decided to
that we should shift to CH and sperm
flagella because these are about 40
micrometers long about eight times as
long as the tetrahymena cilia their
motility had already been studied by Sir
James Gray who's shown that they
propagate waves along the length of the
for John but we didn't have a real good
source of them in Cambridge
Massachusetts where I was then and so we
waited and an opportunity came up for me
to move to Hawaii University of Hawaii
and decided that would be an opportunity
to switch completely to using sea urchin
sperm since the sea urchin urchin Xin
Hawaii who was sexually ripe all year
round you would have material for
working with them year-round without the
complications what happens that happened
if you're trying to do something like
this in California or on the East Coast
so we moved to Hawaii and then we
started studying the motility in more
detail we we first have measured the
parameters of the bending waves over the
entire life sperm then we took the
membranes off the way we have been doing
from the tetrahymena cilia showed that
they could be reactivated with ATP and
propagated bending waves very nicely
then the question was what was some
Tenakee mechanical force actually going
on inside the axon Ian and Keith summers
who who had my graduate student at the
time had the idea of using trypsin to
weaken the structure he thought that
might do something I had earlier
observed that with tetrahymena you know
they become swollen when you gave them
ATP they didn't slide but they became
swollen so he tried to make this happen
also with the theatre and sperm flagella
but was completely unsuccessful they
didn't do the same trick so he tried
treating them with a bit of trypsin to
see if that would get them to do the
same trick and well it did but it also
did something much more dramatic because
they just seemed to disappear completely
if you took the DMM Rene did isolated
actor names
treated them weekly with trypsin and
then diffused in ATP's slowly from the
edge of the microscope slide as the
front of ATP reached the answer names
they just seemed to fade and disappear
so that something quite dramatic was
going on something that had not happened
with the tetrahymena serie and he wanted
to look at that directly and observe it
I decided to use like dark field
microscopy to watch that the
disappearing of these flagella ex names
so Barbara and I went back one evening
and we looked and we saw it and we were
amazed they really slid apart it's very
dramatic when we were really that was
really one of the high points because it
was obviously demonstrating a very
fundamental mechanism was between of in
the interaction of a motor protein with
the microtubule for the first time and
it was happening under our own eyes one
of the things we did was still was to
get more evidence that the dining was
actually the motor driving the motility
the way we did that was by partially
extracting the 19 arms when we did that
we found that the the beat frequency
decreased proportionate to the fraction
of dynein arms that had been removed and
then we could add that this solubilized
dining back again and the beaten and the
flagella P frequency increased back
almost to its original level as the arms
became rebound that was really the
confirming evidence the last nail in the
coffin or whatever you want to call it
so we've covered the isolation discovery
the ATPase dining to the in-vitro
demonstration that dining can slide
microtubules and that was the underlying
principle mechanism of that gave rise to
cilia and flagella beating so maybe you
can give us a quick tour of dining after
that so at that point we wanted to
tenderize it vehemently which we did and
by that time
namely gels gel electrophoresis had been
discovered and developed so we were able
to start looking at the polypeptides
that were present in our preparations
something that have not been possible
when we did the original extraction of
the zoning because of no gels available
that were appropriate at that time so
that was one of the things we wish we
worked up we purified this atps we
started looking at spell e peptides we
eventually cloned and sequence one of
the polypeptides from the outer arm and
then after we cloned and sequenced it we
started looking at at the different
forms of it because it turned out as
most people discovered with gel
electrophoresis preparations are always
more complicated than you'd like to
think a lot more proteins present among
really like to think so we discovered
that there were about eight or nine
bands had in the electro phoretic
position of the nineteen heavy chains
and so we isolated different ones of
them studied how many there were and
that led to realizing that there are the
doning family of heavy the heavy chains
alone consists of at least nine subframe
release and two of these corresponds to
the two cytoplasmic domains the other
seven are its animal proteins and
sometimes there's more than one
representative of a family present at
one time so usually gelatin teams like
we were using contained 13 actually gene
products so we'd cloned and sequenced
one of these genes the base heavy chain
beta heavy chain around only clone
little bits of others but of course as
time went by other people joined in and
so by now there's a real elaborate tree
showing the nine sub families of the
domain heavy chain form independent sub
families that are were present even in
the last common ancestor of all
eukaryotes in 1997 we wanted to retire
from University of Hawaii
what not lesson lesson full-time so we
moved to California where our family
needs to be closer to our family their
children and and there I started working
on the cytoplasmic microtubule binding
domain a cytoplasmic Tony and by taking
just that separate small piece that
constitutes the microtubule binding
domain and it's called crosstalk which
is only about 5% of the total heavy
chain site of the mass of the whole to
hold I mean heavy chain we were able to
express it in bacteria study its
properties we were able to show that by
changing the register between the two
strands of the code crosstalk we could
modulate the binding the affinity the
constant with which the the this set
this this expressed microtubule binding
domain would bind to native might
cytoplasmic microtubules having got
there and having this expressed a
functional Michael society placement
microtubule binding domain next step
obviously was to draw on and crystallize
it and to get a structure took a year
but John Gerber you know and in my lab
did a wonderful job and then helped
especially with the crystallography we
joined Andrew Carter from from your own
lab and together we managed to get a
reasonable atomic level structure for
microtubule binding domain are there any
particular thoughts that you have just
looking back over this my general modus
operandi I think has been to work with a
technique for a while and if it seems to
be sticking try another side to try
climbing another side of the mountain
changed your technique and start afresh
and approach it in a completely
different way I mean and I think that's
that's useful I've certainly found it
interesting I don't know whether how
well it will work today where there many
more people in science and most pop
problems and more popular
competition might make it difficult for
you to do that but certainly it worked
very well for me and so I would
encourage anyone else to try doing it
if they have the opportunity but the
main thing is to have fun enjoy what
you're doing and then with any kind of
decent like your data break result
you